you are watching cold future TV hi
welcome to another cold fusion video to
go though here okay so what's going on
here
it seems that Samsung is planning to
produce an 11 came over screen this
surely is ridiculous has the technology
department at the South Korean company
finally just lost the plot it may seem
that way but let's find out more
according to Korea IT news Samsung is
teaming up with over 13 local and
international companies to try and have
11k display phones by 2018 what's
interesting here is that the South
Korean government itself is investing
twenty six point five million dollars
over the course of five years to make
this a reality which I think puts a
slightly nationalistic spin on things
but more on this later so an eleven k
resolution is obviously hard for us to
fathom as people living in 2015 today's
technology of 2.5 k phones pales in
comparison so let's put the screen into
perspective you guys out there who love
specs may get a kick out of this
assuming in 2018 that we have similar
screen sizes like we have today an 11 k
display will have a resolution of about
eleven five twenty by sixty 480 pixels
with a pixel density of 2250 PPI for
comparison at galaxy s6 which is the
sharpest phone at the moment has 577 PPI
and an iPhone 6 has 407 put in pixel
terms this screen would have a whopping
74 megapixels a modern 1080p screen is
about 2 megapixels and a 4k display is
about 8 megapixels so that's all well
and good but the question must be asked
and this is probably what you're all
wondering what is the point well the
point actually may not be what you think
what you're about to hear is the primary
point according to Samsung's display
executive to hear young and I quote we
are hoping that we are able to show
these technologies at the Pyeongchang
Winter
Olympics in Korea end quote it's
basically primarily to show us South
Korea's technological prowess on the
world stage while everyone is looking
you can now see why the South Korean
government has a direct interest in this
young goes on to say quote although some
might think that xi K is over
specification that consumers do not need
this can work as a basis for the Korean
display industry to take another leap
if related materials and parts improve
through this end quote so basically the
secondary goal is that Samsung wants to
move the whole display industry forward
so is it possible well at the moment is
hard to say directly on my end but I'd
assume that with twenty six million
dollars of direct funding a lot of
progress will no doubt be made so
another question that's quite important
what about the practical uses what is
such a high-resolution screen on a
mobile phone going to be useful for well
one obvious use is mobile virtual
reality an area where today's 2.5
screens for well short of the clarity
needed to mimic real life another such
application is mobile convergence where
a user can make use of mirrored
projection on a much larger screen size
with external inputs such as a keyboard
and mouse okay but obviously there's
going to be some drawbacks right what
other negatives well obviously the more
pixels you have the more power it takes
to keep them lit in the heart of the
onboard graphics unit has to work to
change all those pixels so we'll see a
massive decrease in performance and
power efficiency however this may be
offset by the growth in mobile
performance by 2018 which could be
anywhere from 4 to 16 times more capable
than current day devices so what's the
conclusion here well if I may inject
some personal opinion I think 11k is
overkill to be honest I think 4k
resolution should be a happy ultimate
screen specification for 2018 and beyond
but then again I could be completely
wrong after all
Bill Gates famously stated in 1981 that
640 kilobytes of RAM should be enough
for anyone so what do you guys think
please leave a comment below anyway
thanks for watching this has been - go
go don't forget to give a thumbs up if
you liked it and
subscribe if you're new there's plenty
of other interesting stuff in this
channel and I think you'll have a lot of
fun here cheers guys and I'll see you
again soon for the next video
cold fusion it's me thinking